Speaker 1: OK, why don't we go next to Nisha
from Michigan.
Nisha, you're on the air.
Speaker 2: Oh, my God.
Hi, Dave.
How are you doing?
Speaker 1: I'm doing well, thank you.
Speaker 2: OK, well, I, I've actually been
looking at your show on YouTube, I'd say since
twenty nineteen.
Beautiful much a fan.
I was also on yesterday, but I know you can
reach me because there's a lot of people.
So the whole thing with the direction of in
case I was as shocked as you were.
So I actually didn't even think that they
were going to do it.
But I'm glad that they that they did.
And I don't even know what I could actually
say as a question, because I'm a little I'm
a little bit nervous.
Speaker 1: You're doing great.
Well, listen, let me ask you this.
What is happening in Michigan with covid,
which has been very up and down and much controversy
over covid guidelines?
Speaker 2: Yeah, I think as of right now,
I've even been checking about it myself, so,
I mean, it's like half and I guess half and
half.
I was actually talking to one of my friends,
I think, some days ago, and she said that
she was not really thinking about getting
the vaccine.
And that pretty much was telling her like,
well, it's already said like, if you don't
want to get AstraZeneca one, of course you
have.
No, that's fine, because that has blood clots.
And yeah,
Speaker 1: AstraZeneca is not even approved
in the United States.
Did you mean Johnson and Johnson
Speaker 2: and Johnson and Johnson?
One, of course, is that too.
But I told her that I had my I do have a I
I'm half vaccinated.
So I did give my mother in the vaccine along
with my husband and my mother beautiful.
So I pretty much told her about pretty much
I told her, if you want to go and do either
the Pfizer or the Madrona vaccine, you can
be able to do that.
And she pretty much said that she was skeptical.
Speaker 1: And what is she skeptical of?
Is she skeptical that it works?
She's skeptical of side effects.
Speaker 2: Maybe it might be because of side
effects.
I'm not sure.
But she had told me that I think her aunt
and her grandmother had got it and they were
fully vaccinated.
Yeah.
And I pretty much said, well, that's at least
enough for there.
They're still alive and well.
They're walking and whatnot.
So I'm like, that could at least be proof
right there that it's.
Speaker 1: Yeah, but I mean, it's also like,
you know, hundreds of millions of people around
the world have now been vaccinated.
It's weird when it's like your aunt or something
like that.
My my approach would be this Nesha.
I would always say what is making you hesitant
to get it?
Because sometimes people say, I don't know
that I want to get it.
And it could range from I think there's a
Bill Gates microchip in it to I think there
will be long term side effects to I don't
know that it works, too.
I don't want, you know, whatever.
So try to figure out what is the reason for
the hesitancy and deal with that.
Speaker 2: I don't know, because the whole
thing, the whole Bill Gates thing, I think
that is way too far fetched because that to
me, does that make any type of sense?
I agree with you.
Yeah, I know.
I know.
You would not go that far.
Right.
Speaker 1: OK, ok.
Fair.
Yeah.
Just ask what the hesitation is comes from
and then deal with that head on.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Well and also she had told me that she wanted
to go and wait a year.
I was like, OK, yeah.
I don't think that's really like a good idea
because I mean if you want to go on at least.
Well I kind of don't want to make it sound
like that.
Like pretty much if you want to go on, you
know, for us to hang out again and whatnot
and also go and see my baby.
So, yeah, I mean, I mean, at least get vaccinated
or something.
At least that's some reason I didn't want
to frame it like that.
Sure.
And I don't think I even I don't think I even
told her it.
I don't think I told her like that and that
way either.
So.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: All right.
Well, good, good luck in Michigan.
Nisha said it's going in the right direction,
but it's not happening maybe as quickly as
we would like it.
Speaker 2: Actually, Nisha, though.
Speaker 1: Nisha OK, I apologize.
Speaker 2: It's OK.
It's all right.
Speaker 1: Nisha, a perfect phone call.
I appreciate it.
OK, thank you.
There is Nisha from Michigan.